فيوروسك مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
السيد همم
صاك ضيفنا قبل يقول كما تدين تدان يعني
اوكرانيا سبق وقصفت منطقه مناطق مدنيه في
الدم بس وان هذا العمل كما قال بوتين
واضطراري بسبب استهدافه اوكرانيا اراضي
روسيه مثل القرمه
ما رايه
الو
ليس لدي
رايي بهذا الشان ابدا نحن نتجاهل ما تقوله
روسيا ونحن نتجاهل ما يقوله ممثله هذه
الدوله الارهابيه
وبما في ذلك في هذه النشره اذا انا امل
انه في المره المقبله الضيف سوف يحاكم
بجريمه الاباده وهذا ما يحصل لروسيا هي
تشن حربا فيها عباده جمعيات وروسيا يشارك
اليها على انها دوله ارهابيه من قبل دول
المتعدده بما في ذلك البرلمان الاوروبي
وبالتالي ردنا هو رد عسكري في ميدان
المعركه سوف نستمر بعملياتنا المضاده لسنا
بحاجه لشرح اي شيء العالم يرى خمسون
بالمئه من البنى التحتيه المرتبطه بالطاقه
بدون والعالم باسره يحاول ان يساعد شرق
شعب الاوكراني من خلال ارسال المساعدات
الانسانيه والبطاريات الى اخره وبالتالي
كل شيء تقوله روسيا هو في مكان ولكن
العالم يعرف ما الذي يحصل هذا ارهاب هذا
محض ارهاب وهي اباده جمعيه وبالتالي يجب
ان نتوقف الاستماع اليهم ويجب ان نستمر في
ميدان المعركه وهم يخسرون لم يسيطر على اي
اراضي منذ فتره طويله هذا جلديه نقول طيب
انيته وعد بتقدير دعم خاص
لاوكرانيا لاعاده بناء المنشات الطاقه اين
وصل هذا الوعد
كويس يحصل ان الحكومه الاوكرانيه تحصل على
الدعم من حلف شمال الاطلسي من الاتحاد
الاوروبي تركيا على سبيل المثال ارسلت
ثلاثه سفن لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه في
بناء اوديسا اليوم كان هناك هجوم من قبل
العدو باستخدام الطائره القصيره
وهناك انقطاع شامل للتيار الكهربائي في
اوديسا وبالتالي هذا الارهابي الذي
استضفتموه قبل بغض النظر عما قاله
الملايين من الناس ليس لديهم كهرباء
المستشفيات هي بدون كهرباء
العمليات الجراحيه يجب ان تستمر
بانقطاع التيار الكهربائي ومن خلال
استخدام المواليدات الكهربائيه هذه اباده
لذلك نحن باتجاه
دي سي محكمه دوليه يكون بموجبها محاكمه
لروسيا والقياده الروسيه والشعب الذي
شاركت وايضا اجهزه البروباغندا الروسيه
كلهم يجب ان يحاكم هذا لا يحصل في القرن
الحادي والعشرين سنه 2022